Hello, Ellen DeGeneres.
This is your personalized weather forecast from the brand-new weather.com.
Today, you can expect partly cloudy skies in the morning with the marine layer hanging around,...
...mostly sunny by the afternoon.
Looking good in Los Angeles,...
...not quite merengue weather, but perhaps a good day for some calypso and a little pop and lock.
High temperatures will reach the mid-60s.
Temperatures like this will make you want to straddle your studio coffee table maybe,...
...run into the audience and do some krumping with a random audience member.
Overnight, lows are gonna drop into the low teens.
Seriously, I'm kidding.
The low will only be 55.
If you don't have plans, you can always just stay home, rearrange your closet full of daytime Emmy statues,...
...and spend the rest of the night reading bizarre Craigslist ads.
And don't forget, check back anytime, weather.com, to see what's in store for Socal this weekend.